speaking of people who are confused
here's something that's been making the
rounds on um on Reddit
this is posted by a an account called
males of Reddit
as a screenshot of someone on the the
trans Forum the male to female transform
on Reddit
and here's what they posted they said I
have successfully breast fed my child
this is a male Again by the way my kiddo
was born last week and I was the first
to breastfeed her my partner and I gave
her well they've well they've
they are recognizing the sex of their
daughter so that's something at least
you gotta look for the glimmers of Hope
where you can find them especially in a
situation like this my partner and I
gave her 40 hours of continuous skin to
skin after she was born but after after
months of preparation and trying I was
able to breastfeed my own kiddo from my
breast it's a wild feeling it made me
over the moon happy she's a cutie
and then there are screenshots of a
bunch of comments saying that uh you
know how wonderful all this is
the religion of leftism is anti-religion
which means there isn't anyone to turn
to when things don't go their way
there's no Transcendent being pointing
you toward truth and Beauty there are no
Customs or Traditions to keep you on a
righteous path and there's certainly no
app like hallow to help leftists reclaim
their peace Hollow is an audio guided
prayer and meditation app it's the
number one Christian Prayer app in the
U.S hello it's like calm or headspace
but without the woke nonsense because
it's rooted in Christian faith with
thousands of meditations and prayers I
use hollow to find peace after a long
day of being yelled at by blue haired
zazam weirdos they have over 5 000 audio
guided prayers meditations and Christian
music as well you can pray alongside Jim
Caviezel Bishop bear and father Mike
Schmitz Markle Wahlberg and many more
hello helps me make prayer a priority
and they can do the same for you so get
an exclusive three-month trial at
hallow.com Matt Walsh that's hello.com
Matt Walsh reclaim your piece in this
crazy world download hello today
now it should go without saying but I
feel that I must say it anyway
um
it is not possible for a man to
breastfeed a child
okay that's not something that that can
actually be done you cannot sustain a a
child that way
now what is possible and what has
apparently happened in this case is that
if you take if you're a man and you take
a whole bunch of hormones and you drug
yourself up this way that after a while
you may start secreting some there may
be some secretions that come out of your
nipples which is disgusting but that's
that that may actually happen so these
are going to be hormone these are going
to be these secretions hormone laced
with artificial hormones
that are now being ingested by the child
it could that possibly be remotely
healthy for a newborn child to be
ingesting that whatever that is
okay and we're not going to call it's
not it's not it's not it's not it's not
the mother's milk it's certainly not
that whatever you want to call that
mucus those secretions
uh is it healthy for a child to be
ingesting it
is there any reason to think that it
would be
obviously not
but as always it's not about the child
this is certainly extremely physically
unhealthy for the child not to mention
the psychological damage being done even
at such a young age
but that doesn't matter it's not about
uh it's not about the child it's about
this guy
no this is a this is a a fetish
for him
this is a desire that he has and that he
has now forced a newborn child to
participate in
well I hope you enjoyed that clip from
Matt Walsh show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this YouTube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com And subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on Spotify
Apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts